[Music]
the synchronous firefly ranges
throughout the southern appalachians it
really is a pretty magical thing to see
i think people are just fascinated by
fireflies you know
especially growing up
a lot of people have experiences of
catching fireflies in jars and looking
at how they're doing their flashing you
know looking at them real close maybe it
reminds them of their youth and they
want to bring their children out to
experience the same thing
the synchronous firefly can be
distinguished from other species by its
pattern of six flashes about half a
second apart
it may look somewhat random at first but
when you get a high density of male
splashing
the synchronicity of the dark period is
is very obvious and then the flashing
itself will become synchronous as the
night goes on
generally fireflies do have a similar
appearance
some are larger the predatory ones tend
to be a little bit bigger and there's a
really small species too called the the
blue ghost and it's very small
but generally they're they're a type of
beetle and so they're going to have
this hard outer shell over their wings
that they used to fly with
um and they usually also have a little
bit of red and yellow markings uh right
above their head
and so
you really do have to look at the flash
pattern and some other morphological
characters to tell the species apart
generally the habitat where we find
photinus carolinas is in these low-lying
moist areas where there's kind of a
relatively clear understory so that the
fireflies can visually see each other it
also has to have somewhat of a closed
canopy so that it can be nice and dark
they typically start flashing around 9
30 or 10 but they do wait for it to get
fairly dark
there's a couple of theories as to why
they're synchronous and the female
really does need a large light input in
order for her to respond
that's how she recognizes
the correct species
so when she responds and the males then
know that she's the right female
then they can reproduce there's lots of
other things that are flashing so they
have to have this sort of morse code in
order to be able to know they're with
the right species
[Music]